all right miss candygal does anybody
actually call you that or is that
yeah well actually yes so in high school
everybody called me that can't candy gal
or candy ass because i had a big butt to
be so small so they called me candy ass
or candy cow
all right well let's take a little sharp
pivot from light-hearted to not so
light-hearted
it's been a few weeks now since the
altercation aired
you want me too
how are you feeling i'm i think i'm just
now
starting to get to a place where i can
be light about it when the fight
actually aired it felt like there was a
little bit of a
um a weight that was lifted off of me
and then sort of
finally feeling like people are seeing
what actually happened
versus believing a year of rumors and
lies
there's nothing more gut-wrenching
and frustrating and
just awful about
knowing the truth of something
and having everyone believe that you did
something that you did not do and
not really being able to speak on it
it's like being in prison
it's like being in a prison that you you
can only get out of
when the footage airs and that's how
i have felt for a year
and and i will say this too because
everyone is saying oh candace is not a
victim i'm not a victim
i have always always taken full
responsibility for my mouth
i am a verbal acrobat and i will give
you the business
with this vocabulary all day every day
i've always owned that that is my weapon
but nowhere
in a civilized society
should someone who is communicating
verbally
should that person be physically
accosted because the other party
cannot measure up to my verbal
acrobatics
when the episode aired is that the first
time you saw the footage
no when we pressed charges we were given
the raw footage
um to watch i actually did not watch it
until much later because i just
i i could i couldn't i couldn't i just
couldn't watch it
um but i did eventually see it was awful
it was awful to watch if my heart was
like palpitating i was angry all over
again
i was frustrated i was sad i was
embarrassed
um i was every emotion it was every
emotion
i do feel like i felt a shift in the
fandom though once the episode
aired did you see that and feel that
i did um and it's funny because i
that i thought that i would be happier
about it
but it's still i don't want to cry it's
still it doesn't change anything
it doesn't change what happened
i don't have any tissue hold on i have
to go
go grab a tissue in
watching back the footage reliving what
happened to you
did you notice anything new that you
didn't know had happened
in the moment one thing i thought that
my glass was in
my right hand and it was in my left hand
um the glass that did not leave my hand
until after i was pulled down to the
table by the way i think there's
question of if you threw it or if the
tussle just caused you to lose your grip
on it
do you know which was which happened
um i know i didn't throw it when
i was lurched forward that's when i
i suppose the wine hit her in the face
i did not intentionally throw anything
on her
until she had me by my hair and were
punching me in the back of my head you
do see me
whopping the glass in the air because
remember my head is down
i don't know i can't see where anyone is
but at that point i'm fighting for
my wig and my edges okay so
that that is what is called self-defense
i was defending
myself in that moment but for to say
that i
threw the line on her intentionally
or that i threw a glass on her
intentionally is false
that didn't happen and you saw that that
didn't happen in monique
trying to piece together her side of
this story
her memory does not line up with what is
on tape
when the glass of wine went into my face
i remember reaching
and then it was all downhill from there
that is an absolute
lie and why the story seems to change
week
to week literally from october 17th
the day after the altercation to this
day
her story has changed countless times
it's a barrage of poppycock and
and childlike fairy tale stories that
it's sickening at this point it makes me
sick to my stomach
yeah you've been pretty consistent in
saying you feel
as if monique has misrepresented
everything from the jump what do you
think the biggest
lie or spin she's put on it has been
for me the biggest lie and the most
hurtful
most traumatic thing was telling the
blogs
that i initiated the fight by throwing a
glass of wine on her
because that is what i was viciously
attacked for
that's what i got death threats for
that's what i got threatened to have my
ass beat for i've never dealt with
someone who could so egregiously lie
like that and i just can't wrap my mind
around someone
who can sleep at night and not be
remorseful
i think the part of the altercation
that is still a question mark to me is
after monique is restrained in the
hallway
you start shouting at her as if
almost as if you wanted things to
continue where she is
because you're a ghetto ass hood ass
what was happening then i was angry
that's what that was
i was angry and i'm sorry that i'm i'm
allowed to be angry
she held on to me for what felt like 10
minutes
and during that moment i'm not in
fight mode i'm in keep your wig on mode
at that at that time so when i finally
am able to come up
and realized what was happening
i was angry so yes
f you you bleepity bleep bleep bleep
i said those things and
yes they they didn't help the situation
but would i take it back no because i
was angry
and i'm allowed to verbally express
myself that's how
adult humans communicate
would you take back the initial
conversation that started everything
[Music]
get your hand in my face
it did feel like things were escalating
kind of quickly
well things escalate quickly on all
housewives shows don't they
is that not what everyone watches
housewives for is the verbal spats and
the verbal altercations
and the back and forth and then we kiss
and make up and do it all over again
that's what you watch us for you've seen
women
crack glasses on tables
and curse and scream and throw plates
down
you've seen all of that and you've never
in those moments seen anyone
react the way that this person has
reacted
so it's it's it's twofold
yes i would have walked away i wish i
would have walked away and if i could do
it again
i would have walked away but here's the
thing about me walking away
if i had walked away this time
would she have come after me again i
would venture to say yes
i'm actually glad it happened here
versus us maybe getting all the way to
portugal i'd rather we had had that spat
there and not in a foreign country where
it could have
been much worse i don't want a
portuguese jail
i have a bright future i can't be in
portuguese jail
we see in this week's episode you come
to this decision to
press charges so is the goal for her to
go to jail
the goal is for the court system to do
what the court system needs to do
why did you get to the place where you
felt you needed to press charges
this is not something that i wanted to
do it gave me incredible anxiety to have
to even
think about but after
seeing several weeks of
misinformation and lies and
accusations that are just vehemently
false
being skewed against me and then to also
have been
receiving radio silence from her
and i said to myself there has to be a
consequence for what you did
and that was the way that i felt to best
initiate that consequence
we saw in the last episode she said she
wanted to sit down with you
hash things out seemingly apologize i
need to sit down and talk to her i need
to apologize to her
do you think your decision to press
charges maybe stopped her from doing
that
i do not believe that for one second
i think that her sitting down with her
pastor
was a stunt
i think she did it because she had to
and all those tears that she was crying
i believed those tears i believe they
were real
but they were tears for her
embarrassment and for her
not being able to control herself
and you know people have been tagging me
in her public apology where she says
that she's remorseful and she's sorry
i've not heard from that woman
since she put her hands on me
so a public apology is not an apology to
me you're apologizing to
the people to try and retain their
loyalty
that's not an apology
we know she then pressed charges against
you
all charges were eventually dropped why
i don't know why i have my speculations
but
i don't know why they were dropped and i
i
i'm nauseated by the fact that she felt
empowered enough to press charges
against
me i think it just underscores
how low someone has to be
to do that when they know what they did
you have made it very clear you have no
interest
in being on a show with her
moving forward so what does that mean
for your future with
potomac if monique was to be asked back
for the next season that's none of my
business
i'm not an executive i can only do
what's right and what's best for me
i would never want to work with someone
like
her again a friendship is
completely and utterly out of the
question and she really
it's in her best interest to have a seat
and continue to work work
on herself because the way that she has
conducted herself in this entire ordeal
is is less than savory and that's
putting it
very kindly so what does a reunion look
like if it is in person you're in the
same room
you have to talk about this together
yeah um
it's it's a lot of prayer and
you know medication
the flower kind if if that's possible
it's not going to be easy for me
at all i think the only reason
that i'm even okay doing it is because
there is a part of me that
wants to finally put it to bed it's like
it's nice to have that hard stop
and for me the reunion will be that hard
stop on this entire
ordeal and i'll be able to close that
book and
burn it and move forward really mufo
i'm really honestly truly
ready to be done with this entire
incident
and her the aftermath of the fight
there's the snowball effect of what
happened monique did ask me
to write a statement he wrote this
statement as revenge
towards campus you ashley what can you
tell me about
the journey we see you and ashley go on
this second half of the season
there isn't a whole lot i have to say
about ashley i don't find her to be
someone that has
a soul she's just i think she just
she moves in a particular way that does
not work for me
and i i really have nothing to say about
her
i wish her well i suppose
there is what appears to be another
physical altercation or near physical
altercation
and it seems to be between your husband
and ashley's husband
michael you should get them out of my
face shut the [ __ ] up and listen to what
i'm saying
what can you tell me about that alcohol
and perhaps other substances
and crazy people don't mix
they just don't mix well certain people
just need to
should not be allowed to be around the
group and that's been proven
time and time and time again and it's
old
it's old and it makes me feel sorry for
ashley
honestly um that she doesn't think that
she deserves better than someone
like her husband but that's her business
it's very
interesting the way that that all
happens but it was crazy
it was unexpected never expected that to
happen
and crazy like this is our finale really
it's insane what do you have who are you
talking to
who are you talking to you've
pretty much crossed off two names here
monique and ashley
do you want to continue with the show
monique and ashley are not the only two
people on the show so
yes and
ashley is not someone that i
fear for my safety around
she's not someone who um
i'm so disgusted by that i can't be in
the same room as her
i just have no interest in having a
relationship with her
she's not my people
um so that that's that's ashley
okay as far as you know the other person
yes she's
in the ground i notice you will not say
monique's name
you always refer to the cast her
why why won't you say her name
it gives her life it gives someone who
has
really tried to destroy me
life and she doesn't deserve that from
me
she doesn't deserve it i feel like the
last year has been a year of tests for
you
between the altercation
uh past tweets coming up that you had to
reckon with
and then what the world is reckoning
with in terms of
race what have you learned in the last
year about
who candace is and who you want candace
to be um
oh my god bryce my god these questions
um
well the short answer and what i've said
to all my friends when they call to ask
if i'm okay
is clearly
i'm strong enough to handle it because
i'm still here i've learned
that
words have consequences i've learned
that
there is a time and a place for
everything and
i've learned that i'm resilient and
through all of it
somehow i'm still here i'm still blessed
i can really
handle anything and i think the
the goal is to just learn how better to
handle
[Music]
anything
you